mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour nous allons commencer ce tour
d'actualité par le proche orient où la
tension monte cela s'est senti très
nettement hier soir dans la conférence
de presse donnée par le chef d'état
major des forces armées israéliennes
le général barry le général a en effet
dit que le rapport des forces dans le
proche orient a été modifiée par
l'installation de bases de missiles dans
la zone du canal en moins d'une semaine
trois avions israéliens vous le savez on
été abattu par des missiles soviétiques
et l'on peut se demander ce matin c'est
ce que nous avons fait avec jacques
isnard du monde
si ces déclarations publiques du chef
d'état major israélien n'ont pas d'autre
but que de faire pression sur les états
unis pour amener la livraison de
nouveaux matériels de guerre je signale
que jacques isnard rentre à l'instant
d'israël et qu'il va publier dans le
monde aujourd'hui et demain deux
articles consacrés aux entretiens qu'il
a eus avec les principaux dirigeants
militaires avec les principaux chefs
militaires israéliens tout d'abord
quelle est l'impression que vous avez
retiré de ses contacts avec les
militaires israéliens
j'ai eu l'impression je crois justifier
de rencontrer des gens assez
intransigeants c'est à dire des gens qui
ont pour eux la des arguments techniques
qui consiste à dire les frontières que
nous avons à l'heure actuelle sont les
plus sûres sur le plan militaire sont
les plus confortables et en même temps
sont les plus économiques donc nous les
tiendrons jusqu'à ce que nous pourrons
et pour en revenir à cette conférence de
presse du général bas reliefs d'hier
soir est ce que votre avis il n'y a pas
là une volonté très nette de la part
d'israël
d'employer un argument de chantage
vis-à-vis des américains
je crois d'abord qu'il faut partir de
deux faits ils sont les suivants 1 fait
technique et puis un fait historique
un fait technique qui consiste à dire le
système de sam tels que le général
bar-lev l'a décrite nous le connaissons
bien
il a été en activité au vietnam et il a
fait des ravages au vietnam autrement
dit les ravages actuellement ces
systèmes de sam de houssam trois fonds
au le long du canal de suez ses ravages
ne sont pas extraordinairement
supérieurs à ce qu'ils font au vietnam
ça c'est un fait technique un deuxième
fait historique c'est que rappelez-vous
en avril l'intervention ou tout au moins
la présence et l'apparition dans le ciel
égyptien de pilote soviétique aux mains
de mig qui sont des avions interceptions
avait déjà contraint l'état major
israélien a abandonné leur raid en
profondeur au dessus de l'egypte alors
ça c'est un fait historique et nous
avons maintenant le prolongement de ce
fait historique c'est à dire que
l'apparition de ces systèmes de défense
aérien law long du canal
évidemment amoindri l'initiative est
amoindri les possibilités d'action d
israël alors partant de ce fait il est
probable que le général bar-lev exagère
un peu à des fins politiques
l'importance de cette affaire est
principalement je crois que le général
bar-lev a envie de ses avions que sont
les fantômes et les skyrock américain et
c'est pour lui peut-être la meilleure
des façons de mettre au pied du mur la
diplomatie américaine
est ce qu'au cours des entretiens que
vous avez eues en israël vous avez
l'impression que ce pays était gravement
menacée par cette installation domicile
le long du canal de suez
je crois quand même que et là il faut
être objectif sur ce terrain qui est
assez difficile mais simplement sur le
plan technique je crois effectivement à
l'efficacité de ces engins nous les
connaissons bien et nous avons je dirais
même en france je vous états unis à peu
près le même système ce sont les nike
gironde et des systèmes défensifs donc
l'organe mesure est ce qu israël est
menacé vraiment par celle ci ce qui est
le cas pour l'état major israël
l'objectif reste l'offensive
essentiellement il est certain que cette
offensive est considérablement limité
par la présence à moins de 40 km du
canal de ses systèmes de défense
peut-on dire que la paix
ou le retour de la paix est compromis
par l'installation de ces missiles
l'anah je ne pense pas que sur le plan
militaire à long terme ça soit
effectivement un pas en avant a franchi
par les soviétiques important mais je
crois que le pas en avant qui menacerait
la situation au moyen-orient ce moment
serait une intervention américaine
on a parlé de la possibilité pour le
président nixon de détacher quelques-uns
de ses porte-avions la sixième flotte au
moyen-orient et principalement
méditerranée orientale
je ne pense pas effectivement que les
porte avions américain fasse grand chose
mais ils peuvent apporter un appui aux
israéliens sous forme si vous voulez de
reconnaissance photographique ou de
possibilité d'échanger des informations
de défense aérienne qui effectivement
aiderait beaucoup les emails une
dernière un dernier mot après votre
voyage en israël parce que vous avez
l'impression que la balle politique est
fait par les militaires pesée des
rencontres et je crois que dans un pays
qui consacre l'équivalent de 50 % de son
budget national aux affaires militaires
dans un pays où les généraux en plus
souvent la parole qu'à leur tour et où
ses généraux d'ailleurs sont beaucoup
plus prolixe lorsqu'il parle de la
situation politique que lorsqu'il parle
des rapports de forces en présence dans
ces pays là il est certain que les
généraux les chefs militaires du manière
générale joue un rôle de pressions
politiques et même industriel assez
important nous faisons de recevoir
l'instant une dépêche de new york les
dernières propositions soviétique sur le
proche-orient contiennent certains
éléments nouveaux concret et réaliste
pour une paix durable dans cette région
du monde c'est ce qu'estime le
secrétaire général des nations unies ou
tandis qu'en pensez vous et monsieur du
temps de koné au mieux la situation que
moi je pense que sa déclaration est
quand même relativement optimiste et
vous ne pensez pas qu elle arrive juste
à un moment où l'on sent que les israël
c'est probablement et c'est d'ailleurs
l'une des explications du de la ferme du
général parlait je vous remercie à amman
a été signé tard dans la nuit dans la
nuit d'hier un accord de coexistence
pacifique entre les organisations
palestiniennes et la jordanie cet accord
accorderait une liberté d'action
complète au fedayin et préciserait
également une volonté réciproque de non
ingérence
les autres nouvelles de l'étranger en
italie c'est la nouvelle crise politique
qui est l'objet des commentaires de tous
les journaux de ce matin il popolo
souligne que monsieur roux mort a
démissionné pour permettre aux quatre
partis de clarifier leurs engagements et
beaucoup l'eau et le jeu
de la tendance de monsieur remords le
corriere della serra se demande s'il
existe encore une possibilité de
reconduire la coalition de centre gauche
on apprend d'autre part que monsieur
brejnev chef du parti communiste de
l'union soviétique qui a annulé son
voyage en roumanie pour raisons de santé
a assisté hier soir à moscou un match de
football c'est monsieur kossyguine qui
est à bucarest
l'actualité sociale en france maintenant
le suspense continue pour la navigation
aérienne
pas d'accord hier après cinq heures de
discussions mais un protocole d'accord
protocole d'accord qui est un bilan des
négociations et ce protocole va être
soumis aux différentes catégories de
personnel de la navigation aérienne
c'est à dire que si la base est
satisfaite et bien l'accord sera signé
sera signée le 15 juillet prochain à la
sortie des négociations voici ce que
nous ont dit un syndicaliste et le
ministre des transports par intérim
monsieur galets le syndicat cftc des
contrôleurs aériens a été le plus dur
pendant ces négociations à la fin de
cette journée il y aura-t-il des grève
ou pas grève du zèle ou trafic normal à
orly à ses voeux personnels qui vend à
décider nous avons quant à nous lui
présenter les points d'accord les points
de désaccord
un protocole d'accord a été préparé
aujourd'hui signature normalement le 15
juillet
le protocole nous l'avons dit monsieur
le ministre est incomplet sur quel point
il arrive à son terme
la négociation arrive à son terme dans
le cadre fixé par le ministre et le
gouvernement sur le point essentiel les
deux points essentiels que nous avions
soulevé liberté syndicale et
reclassement de la profession sur la
base des responsabilités de contrôle sur
ces bases la discussion ne s'est pas
encore établi et pourquoi la cftc at
elle été si dur durant ces négociations
parce qu'elle estime que son dossier est
solide et qu'elle a l'habitude d'aller
jusqu'au bout lorsqu'elle estime que son
dossier est solide malgré tous les
inconvénients que cela peut provoquer
dans le public et orly on peut avoir des
opinions diverses sur les
responsabilités de ces inconvénients
quant à nous nous menons la négociation
depuis les accords de juin 68 qui
prévoyait la mise en place d'une
commission et qui est là qu'une
commission a été chargée d'établir le
dossier de navigation aérienne pour vous
ce dossier n'est pas terminée les
problèmes essentiels ne sont pas encore
abordé précieux ministre c'était
aujourd'hui je crois la 13e rencontre
avec les syndicats alors ce soir il ait
eu un protocole d'accord mais pas
d'accord de signer pourquoi oui il y a
eu un protocole qui a été établi il
reste un certain nombre de questions
fondamentales qui ont été à
dès ce soir je veux parler de la date de
mise en application de ce protocole je
proposais le 1er juillet 1970 et la
durée d'application de ce protocole
j'ai proposé le 31 décembre 1962 tous
alors naturellement les organisations
syndicales qui avaient demandé les
quantités précision qui avait obtenu un
certain nombre d'amendements qui avait
obtenu des modifications de rédaction
qui avait obtenu des modifications du
fond même de l'usiné ont demandé devant
ce monument qu'on représente un
protocole d'une vingtaine de pages un
délai de réflexion pour pouvoir
consulter leur mandat
d'après la cftc la décision du la
poursuite de la grève du zèle dépend des
employés mais il n'est pas impossible
que la grève du zèle se poursuivre d'ici
le 15 juillet qu'allez vous faire
je crois que les organisations
syndicales pas plus que les officiers
contrôleurs ou non le moindre intérêt
durant cette période qui est une période
d'attentes dans lequel personne ne peut
rien puisqu'on consulter les personnels
à précipiter les choses et en
particulier à reprendre cette grève que
je continue à appeler la grève de la
désorganisation de la navigation
aérienne
le préfet de la corse vient d'annoncer
que les listes électorales allait être
systématiquement vérifier à partir du
mois de septembre dans toutes les
communes de corse le préfet a précisé
que ces listes étaient exagérément
gonflé c'est son mot et que
l'administration prendrait des mesures
très sévères lorsque des inscriptions
frauduleuses seront décelés à linge et
cela restera détenu à la prison de
fresnes monsieur galmiche premier juge
d'instruction en effet rejeté sa demande
de mise en liberté provisoire à blois
congrès du cnj ya sadique à l'hypnose
police syndicalisme et politique rapport
de l'action syndicale et de l'engagement
politique loi au 12e congrès du centre
national des jeunes agriculteurs
après deux jours de débats l'équipe
réformiste c'est-à-dire partisans d'une
amélioration du sort des agriculteurs à
l'intérieur du système économique actuel
conserve la direction du cnj a avec le
nouveau président vincent gomer et le
secrétaire général louis louga
mais elle aura face à elle une
opposition forte et organisée
d'inspiration psu il est certain que ce
conflit interne que la montée des
contestataires a réveillé le cnj a qui
sommeillait depuis quelques
année il faut donc s'attendre maintenant
à un durcissement du cnj a vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs publics dans chacune de ses
actions le cnj a devra en effet tenir
compte de sa forte opposition
le leader de ces contestataires antoine
richard et président du centre régional
des jeunes agriculteurs de la région
rhône alpes
âgé de 29 ans maraîcher près de
saint-etienne
antoine richard et son équipe estiment
que la politique de concertation avec
les pouvoirs publics abouti en fait à
une complicité du syndicalisme il faut
dit-il convaincre les paysans davis du
capitalisme et des chances qu'offre une
société socialiste antoine richard vous
êtes leaders de l'opposition
certains vous traite de gauchistes
qu'en pensez vous il est facile
évidemment de coller des âges et des
adjectifs sur les uns sur les autres
il est facile de dire que notre démarche
a été inspiré par un parti politique ou
par des groupuscules plus ou moins égaux
fils tout nous ça nous fait simplement
sourire parce que notre démarche était
syndicale ce à partir des difficultés
des jeunes agriculteurs dans les cantons
que petit à petit on a recherché les
moyens pour s'en sortir avec l'ensemble
de nos adhérents et on en est arrivé à
une réflexion sur la société une
condamnation de la société actuelle
libéral ou finalement celui qui est
riche et fort et toujours plus plus
libre que celui qui est faible et à
rechercher les moyens pour que les aider
les agriculteurs soient à l'aise dans la
société
c'est donc à partir de l'ocs condamnant
la société libérale actuelle
on a dit il faut une société où
l'économie se service de tous et pour
cette raison qu'elle soit gérée par tous
donc ça s'appelle en clair une société
socialiste le congrès vient de se
terminer quelles conclusions tirez-vous
de ce combat pour la première fois
l'opposition s'est rassemblée autour de
deux rapports autour des idées émises
sur un papier non pas simplement au tour
des hommes et ça a été payant puisque
finalement notre rapport a rassemblé 118
voix canton 145 à l'autre rapport
officiel donc finalement c'est un
excellent résultat pour nous il faudra
compter avec nous et nous apporterons au
maximum nous acceptons la démocratie de
l'organisation nous travaillerons
maximum dans le sensia dans les
commissions et au conseil
d'administration mais il est bien
évident qu'il faudra compter avec nous
oui c'était là la thèse de l'opposition
et vous présentant tout de suite après
ce journal c'est à dire un 13h30
le représentant du de la tendance
majoritaire monsieur louis louga qui a
été élu secrétaire national du cnj à
secrétaire général du cnj réunion de
travail ce matin à l'elysée à paris
messieurs pompidou chaban delmas et
giscard d'estaing ont fixé le plafond
des dépenses pour 1971 cet après midi
monsieur pompidou un entretien avec le
président de la république du gabon
monsieur bongo qui a quant à lui ce
matin poursuivi sa visite de paris 2eme
journée donc de la visite officielle du
président albert bernard bongo journée
qu'il a commencé par un hommage rendu au
soldat inconnu à l'arc de triomphe il
faisait très beau ce matin et c'est sous
un magnifique soleil que le cortège
officiel à remonter l'avenue des
champs-elysées tout pavoisée aux
couleurs gabonaise et française
à 10h30 le président gabonais accompagné
du premier ministre monsieur jacques
chaban delmas
arrivé à l'arc de triomphe où il est
accueilli par messieurs henri duvillard
ministre des anciens combattants et
andré fontes ont secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de la défense
c'était la cérémonie habituelle de dépôt
des gerbes
la rubrique des accidents accident
d'hélicoptère en autriche à
berchtesgaden
il y a six morts non il ya dix morts
dont six militaires français on n'a pas
d'autres détails c'est un télégramme que
je viens de recevoir l'instant un mort
deux disparus plus de 10 millions de
francs de dégâts c'est le bilan d'une
explosion due à une fuite de gaz qui
s'est produit ce matin à 8h30 dans la
haute-marne à chaumont l'immeuble qui
abritait le quotidien la haute-marne
libéré a été soufflée par cette
explosion
les huit rédacteur du journal ont
échappé à l'accident mais trois employés
de la photogravure ont été pris sous les
décombres et vraisemblablement tué
importante à 110 également dans la
banlieue de lille un reportage de notre
station régionale
un violent incendie s'est déclaré hier
matin à lille dans une fabrique de
revêtements de sols de matières
plastiques qui emploie près de 200
personnes
le feu s'est semble-t-il déclaré vers 10
heures 30 au premier étage de l'immeuble
34e grosses lances des casernes de
pompiers de l'île de tourcoing de
roubaix des environs ont été mises en
batterie pour lutter contre un incendie
qui d'heure en heure redoubler de
violence
au fur et à mesure les murs extérieurs
de les planchers des étages s'écroulent
r par chance il n'y a aucune victime
parmi les sauveteurs
vers 15 heures l'incendié était
circonscrit une disparition est à
déplorer celle de monsieur peau elle se
nomme foyer de lusine qui errent soir
n'était pas rentré chez lui d'après une
première évaluation les dégâts sont
estimés à 4 millions de francs
une précision c'est bien tout à l'heure
à 13h30 après ce journal que vous
pourrez voir au cours de l'émission télé
village un portrait du leader de la
tendance majoritaire du cnj à monsieur
louis louga élue secrétaire générale
hier une conséquence de départ en
vacances un cambriolage quatre jeunes
gangsters se sont introduits après midi
dans un appartement du 16e
arrondissement de paris ils se sont
emparés d'une somme de 200 mille francs
la lutte contre le tabac est mené
activement dans au moins 25 pays dans
cette nation il n'est pratiquement rien
fait par contre pour décourager les
fumeurs selon une étude effectuée par le
service de santé des états unis
d'amérique
parmi les 25 pays à l'honneur figurent
les etats-unis la france et l'allemagne
occidentale est également la bulgarie
dont la réglementation suivantes est
cité en exemple un fumeur bulgares ne
peut fumer pendant le travail que s'il
obtient l'autorisation de ses camarades
qui ne sont pas fumeur
autre il est interdit de fumer dans une
salle où travaillent des femmes
enceintes ou des jeunes mères aux états
unis pour la première fois des femmes
participent à une expérience sous marine
écoutons françois de closets la première
femme cosmonaute fut la soviétique
valentina terechkova les premières
femmes aquanautes sont américaines en
effet cinq jeunes femmes ont plongé
lundi au large des îles de la vierge
dans le pacifique pour participer à
l'expérience techt it 2 une réplique
américaine des expériences près
continent du commandant cousteau
durant quinze jours elles vont vivre et
travailler sous l'eau à une profondeur
relativement modeste de 15 m une
concession à l'élégance féminine ces
dames dispose d'un séchoir à cheveux
dans leurs maisons sous-marines haute de
15 m
c'est jeune plongeuse ne sont pas
seulement des sportifs accomplis mais
surtout des scientifiques de grande
valeur docteur en biologie spécialiste
d'écologie marine
elles vont consacrer ces deux semaines
de vie sous-marine a effectué de
nombreuses expériences scientifiques
quant au programme technique 2 il se
poursuivra sur une durée de 7 mois
les plongeurs restent en majorité dans
l'équipe
ces hommes pour cinq femmes l'espace
intérieur ainsi que les spécialistes
appellent les océans reste une conquêtes
masculines
tout comme l'espace extérieur
la rubrique sportive à un record a été
établi dans les pyrénées atlantiques
c'est une poule 2 mirepeix qui a pondu
un oeuf qui pesait 200 g c'est-à-dire
quatre fois le poids d'un oeuf normal
mais la détentrice du record
malheureusement il morte peu de temps
après son exploit et d'autres records
une semaine je pense qu'il y encore
beaucoup plus sérieux qui sont établis
de ma soirée jeudi
parce que vous savez que cela grand l'on
compte entre la france et les états unis
grande rencontre d'athlétisme
les américains sont déjà arrivés à paris
ils ont pu assister à un spectacle sic
curieux sur les champs-elysées les
américains qui trottine dans les tenues
diverses il y en a encore qui y en a en
bermuda sur cette photo de france soir
on connaît tornac est un spécialiste du
200 m partie de la gauche
art qui est un spécialiste du 4 x 100 m
skimmer collins soit seul qui sera
alignée dans le 800 mètres et ils qui
courra sur 110 m haies frankfurter lui
s'est distingué à sa façon c'est un
garçon qui est spécialiste du 5000 m
pour se mettre en jambes y est allée de
l'étoile à notre-dame en petite tenue
ça fait quand même à ses sensations les
badauds qui est plutôt étonné tour de
france tour de france vous devinerez
jamais qui est l'initiateur élimé axe a
gagné l'étape contre la montre il a
gagné à près de 50 km heure de moyenne
49 836 exactement le second et gonzalez
linares l'espagnol à 9 secondes
merckx possède maintenant trois minutes
d'avancé au classement général sur une
thématique agostini lui c'est un pilote
de moto qui domine le sport motocycliste
de la même façon qu'eddy merckx domino
tour de france pilote italien vient de
remporter encore une victoire sur le
circuit de francorchamps
il pleuvait sur le circuit vous allez le
voir c'est très impressionnant et c'est
toujours très très impressionnant car
vraiment ces motos qui se lance dans les
courbes
alors que la piste ressemble à une
patinoire c'est un spectacle qui fait
frémir
giacomo agostini vous allez voir
apparaître le numéro 6 il pilote une mv
agusta de cinq centimètres cubes le suit
en tête il est suivi par un français
christian ravel qui vient de passer sur
kawasaki et qui s'affirme comme un
excellent pilote mais ravel n'a jamais
pu contester la suprématie du m lemaitre
agostini il terminera second avec trois
minutes de retard sur agostini
malgré la pluie l'emportent à la moyenne
assez extraordinaire de 178 km heure
agostini a déjà gagné six grand prix
motocycliste depuis le début de la
saison
à 25 ans il est parti pour un nouveau
titre de champion du monde c'est aussi
un très très beau garçon il ya
d'ailleurs de tourner un film
autre spécialité motocycliste le side
car et là vous pouvez constater que
l'équipier fait un travail très
particulier utilisant son corps comme un
contrepoids dans les virages bien nous
on encore parler d'aviation et je vais
céder la parole à chacun de nexans
bien oui effectivement nous allons
parler d'une grande aviatrice
puisqu'elle a il ya près de 50 ans
franchit la cordillère des andes par la
phase la plus meurtrière vous avez
certainement reconnu que je parlais
d'adrienne bolland c'est un reportage de
daniel cazals à 75 ans adrienne bolland
vient de faire en touriste le tour du
monde
il y à 50 ans elle avait été la première
femme pilote à franchir la cordillère
des andes
oui j'étais premières femmes pilotes
s'est entendu mais j'aime y était le
premier pilote à franchir par l'endroit
où je les fais ça avait été fait au nord
et au sud mais pas par la sppe rêvasse
vous aviez que l'argent l'époque j'avais
un peu plus de 25 ans je venais d'avoir
25 ans une barrière de 4000 m qu'est ce
que ça représentait en 1921 pour une
femme pilote
vous savez ça représentait la même chose
pour un homme pour une femme puisque il
s'était tué ses nombreux dans le passage
que j'ai emprunté j'ai emprunté celui là
parce que ceux qui avaient voulu prendre
ce été tuées et vous étiez à bord d'un
caudron voyez ce coton plein ficelles
qui n'avait même pas un véritable
fuselage
ils montent à quelle altitude cet
appareil
vous savez y monter dans les 4000 le col
avec 4000 2000 paraît que j'ai dû
profiter bénéficient plutôt de courant
ascendant mais je ne veux même pas que
ça existait j'avais quarante heures de
vol et tout ce que j'avais sur volcom
montagne c'était les collines de
picardie je ne savais rien qu'en sus
partie absolument rien je n'avais ni
carte ni compas vous avez établi un
record de looping aussi pris en 24 c'est
ça combien 212 en 73 minutes
et qu'est ce que ça représente ça abbas
a représentait pas et ce que je voulais
faire c'est dingue qui m'a plaqué qu'est
ce que vous vouliez faire
or je voulais dépasser les mille parce
que à ce moment là il y avait un pilote
et un pilote remarquable qui s'appelait
fronval et qui lui en avait fait en 111
j'avais dit mon vieux moi j'en ferais au
moins aux 112 et puis les zincs est
quelqu'un en route et vais plus rien à
faire il vous abandonnez rêver sinon je
te renard en choeur est ce que vous
aviez plus d'appréhension
en montant dans un avion en 1921 que
vous n'en avez aujourd'hui c'est je vous
le disais j'ai j'ai toujours eu peur
mais il faut que j'aille où j'ai peur ça
c'est une attraction formidable
maintenant je peux vous dire que dans
les boeing se juge sue complètement
décontracté ça veut pas dire que j'ai
été contractés dans les miens parce que
j'aurais pas pu puis le tennis faire ce
que j'ai fait mais j'avais quand même
quelque chose à plaindre
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir eu en tant que femme une vie
assez exceptionnel tout de même oui j'ai
eu une vie je peux dire est très
exceptionnel seulement je ne peux pas
dire que j'ai eu une vie festive
les gens disent vous avez eu une belle
vie c'est pas vrai j'ai pas eu une belle
vie
j'ai eu une vie
exceptionnel et sensationnel et là vous
venez d'un vous revenez d'un tour du
monde
oui je reviens d'un tour du monde c'est
tout de même assez extraordinaire à 75
ans de faire un tour du monde en avion
au jeu pourquoi je vois pas pourquoi je
pense que c'est pas mon dernier
nous allons maintenant nous adresser à
des sportifs qui prennent beaucoup moins
de risque puisqu'il s'agit des pêcheurs
kristen de la croix a rétabli pour une
chronique juridique
attention attention sa mort au qu'il est
beau le rêve de tout pêcheur une pièce
rare on en parlera longtemps et
longuement impatients volant d'une
voiture le français aime passer des
heures 30 il a regardé le fil de sa
ligne jouer sur l'eau mais toujours dans
son droit lorsqu'on taquinent le poisson
m peut-on pêcher à la ligne sans permis
de pêche oui mais c'est assez limité
il faut être mineur de 16 ans les
mineurs de 16 ans peuvent pêcher sans
faire partie d'une association de pêche
et de pisciculture
au delà de 16 ans vont au delà de 16 ans
il faut faire partie d'une telle
association il faut surtout avoir à
acquitter la taxe piscicole le permis de
pêche m est valable à la fois pour le
mari et pour sa femme
certainement le conjoint peut pêcher
sans avoir de coeur en fait on ne peut
pas pêcher et n'importe quoi n'importe
où ce radicalement impossible à moins
que des deux propriétaires d'une mare
d'un étang d'un lac d'un réservoir ça
c'est la pêche dans les eaux closes dans
les zoo privé est absolument libre et
indépendante
mais là le poisson n'est pas libre le
poisson appartient au propriétaire de la
maraude les temps ou alors quels sont
les infractions les plus graves et
commence été sanctionné les infractions
les plus graves
il ya la pêche à l'aide d'engins
prohibée c'est la pêche à l'aide
d'explosifs ou la pêche
à l'aide de filets non réglementaire la
pêche la nuit où la pêche à la l'aide de
moyens d'électrocution c'est assez
sévèrement sanctionnés par une peine
damon et ça peut même aller jusqu'à une
peine d'emprisonnement notamment si ça
se passe la nuit et en cas de récidive
quelques le délit contraventionnelle
délit contraventionnelle suppose qu'il
n'y a pas d'intention délictuelles
autrement dit on ne se préoccupe pas de
la bonne foi du délinquant
peu importe il est une intention ou non
de commettre le délit l'essentiel c'est
qu'il ait commis l'infraction tout
pêcheur est censé connaître la loi il
doit savoir aussi qu'il lui faut rejeter
à l'eau certains poissons qui a mordu au
bout de sa ligne
s'il aventure vous pêchez un esturgeon
qui à moins d'un mètre quarante cinq
vous devez leur jeter à l'eau de même
qu'un saumon s'il a moins de 48 cm en ce
qui concerne le brochet s'il a moins de
40 cm il faut leur jeter à l'eau de même
que la cendre si elle a moins de 36 cm
si vous l'avez la chance d'attraper une
truite et si elle a moins de 23 cm de
même qu'un nom le chevalier qui est un
poisson précieux il faut leur jeter à
l'eau voilà quels sont les principes
alors pour mesurer le poisson on part du
zoo on va jusqu'au bout de la queue on
ne peut pas pêcher à toute heure so lu
ment pas la pêche est permise
une demi-heure avant le lever du soleil
jusqu'à une demi heure après le coucher
du soleil
en règle générale que peut-on dire en
matière de pêche en matière de pêche
c'est bien le législateur a fait sienne
la doctrine de monsieur de la palisse
est permis tout ce qui n'est pas défendu
comme vous avez pu l'observer nous avons
eu un petit ennui avec le télé cinéma au
début de ce sujet je le regrette pour
les pêcheurs car nous avions prévu de
vous montrer de très belles pièces
il est maintenant l'heure de passer à la
bourse de paris avoue jean-michel 4
points et bien la bourse de paris
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de belles pts
le marché baisse vous savez que les
boursiers garde toujours un officier sur
wall street
or vendredi les marchés américains
étaient fermés en raison de la fête
nationale 2
pas lens b aussi attendez attendez ton
avec quelques curiosités et la ré
ouverture hier de wall street mais à
ceux qui escomptaient une hausse en ont
été pour leurs frais l'indicé dow jones
a perdu près de 15 points voilà coup sûr
qui n'encourage pas les éventuels
acheteurs et aussi ne faut pas s'étonner
que l'ensemble de la cote ces prix
aujourd'hui à paris mais nous allons
passer tout de suite à la vedette d'hier
à etsaut vu hier le titre avait gagné 6%
cette hausse était motivée par la
découverte d' indices d'huile et de gaz
dans un forage situé dans le rhône
mais ce ne sont que des indices est
aujourd'hui le titre se replie à 115,50
il perd donc que deux francs 50 par
rapport à son plus haut cours d'hier
mais pendant que la caméra va vous
donner les différents cours
je voudrais vous parler de la nouvelle
recrue accueilli hier à la bourse de
paris
la société financière pour l'expansion
des télécommunications plus communément
appelée fille nextel l'objet de cette
société est ambitieux ne s'agit pas
moins que de financer une grande partie
des investissements nécessaires pour
résoudre la crise du téléphone le retard
pris par la france dans ce domaine
atteint des proportions inquiétantes
chacun d'entre nous en a malheureusement
fait l'expérience
la situation empirant le gouvernement a
décidé il ya un an s'attaquer au
problème
celui ci ont sans doute aidé est
essentiellement d'ordre financier le
budget des ptt ne pouvait pas suffi à
rattraper le retard
par ailleurs il n'était pas possible de
demander beaucoup plus à l'utilisateur
du téléphone ni aux contribuables et
ceci pour des raisons bien évidentes les
constructeurs eux ne peuvent pas se
permettre de faire crédit
quant à l'administration l'importance
des sommes nécessaires
la met dans l'impossibilité de payer
comptant fayoum trouver de l'argent
ailleurs
et là il n'y avait pas 36 solutions il
fallait s'adresser au secteur privé aux
épargnants c'est ainsi que naquit l'idée
d'une société privée drainant une partie
de l'est par le finançant les programmes
d'équipement téléphone avec fille nextel
on mettait à l'intermédiaire entre les
constructeurs et l'administration
son rôle est donc d'acheter aux indes le
matériel et de leur vendre d'autres
selon la formule du leasing est une
sorte de crédit bail sur dix ans une
location vente en cas que ça
on espère ainsi que tout le monde y
trouvera son compte les constructeurs
qui verront leurs ventes augmenter
considérablement les utilisateurs qui
devrait ainsi avoir un meilleur réseau
téléphonique
les épargnants qui vont avoir envie
nextel 1 titres indexés la société
donnera en effet un dividende annuel
provenant de loyers versés par
administration
de plus cette dernière versera un
complément indexé sur l'évolution du
chiffre d'affaires des
télécommunications fille nextel compte
verser à ses actionnaires un intérêt
annuel moyen d'environ 8,3 pour cent
ceci dans un rapport bien sûr au nominal
de 100 francs les principes de
fonctionnement étant ainsi posé il
fallait passer à la réalisation
la première étape fut la naissance
officielle du finistère
ce fut chose faite en septembre 1969
cinq grandes banques fournissait 10
millions de francs qui c'est vrai est
ainsi de base de départ seconde étape
faire participer le public c'est à dire
lui demander d'apporter son argent en
mars dernier près de 4 millions
d'actions fine extel furent offertes aux
épargnants au prix de 100 francs la
campagne publicitaire l'originalité de
la formule fier de cette opération un
succès enfin hier c'était la troisième
étape
l'introduction officielle à la bourse de
paris et on n'a qu